hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the morphe
saga and we left it off
in the match 1858 match against daniel
harvest in paris and
morphe is not doing all that great uh as
as you already know morphe lost the
first exhibition game where he
was kind of forced to accept the king's
gambit but then he also lost
the two first um games of the uh actual
official games of the match
uh but then like we said uh in the
previous video
we said that uh harvest will not win a
single game
uh something uh uh morphy mentioned to
the edge and also
uh it's very interesting that um it's
very interesting how uh
uh everyone was very weird because
people placed a lot of bets on morphe he
was uh
known to be a very strong guy and uh
interestingly after the two games that
we've shown
uh morphe was having dinner with edge
and he was joined by
daniel harvest here who uh was enjoying
the the food
as well as they did but he was also uh
gloating
and he was you know feeling super proud
that he defeated morphy uh
in two games uh but this is what edge
said
the harvest during that uh dinner he
said i'm sorry mr harvest you have not
found
mr morphy in good fighting thr fighting
trim
the fact is he has been preparing to
meet you by not going to bed until
common men are about to rise but he has
promised to retire early in the future
and you will then find him to be a very
different antagonist
so uh hopefully morphe went to bed early
before game three and now
let's see uh what happens in this one
and as you see the quote above the board
something wilhelm steinitz
mentioned about the second game uh the
one that we showed as the first game if
you've been following so far
uh that he has no satisfactory
explanation is given of how morphy lost
it it is an explanation
that only morphe could have given and
probably did
to someone like his companion um uh edu
but
to us it is unknown but most likely due
to morphe not even
taking the match seriously so far so
let's see what happens now when morphe
uh uh when morphe starts taking the
match seriously so harvest with the
white pieces
again opens with d4 but this time morphe
doesn't allow him to go for some sort of
a queen's gambit decline setup
uh rather he goes for f5 a very exotic
dutch defense
so let's see how harvest deals with the
dutch we have c4
uh e6 by morphe knight to c3 and now
knight to f6
uh we have bishop to g5 attacking the
knight here
and now bishop to b4 pinning the knight
here so
about players fighting for the center
and now queen to b3
uh putting pressure on that bishop and
morphy uh
in a very uh modern fashion goes c5
defends the bishop here and
immediately attacks the d4 pawn and
already here white could go wrong by
going something like a3
black very happily trades here and then
gets a nice developing knight to the c6
with
tempo and the black is very happy with
uh with such a setup so instead
after this c5 harvest grabs more space
in the center we have d5
and now morphe uh doesn't allow any
trades he plays e5 and already morphe is
controlling a lot of space in
here in the center as you can see uh and
here e3
this is uh maybe not the the greatest of
moves
e4 would have been uh more ambitious but
it's
uh it's hard to play such a move because
it's a temporary pawn sacrifice then you
go knights to e2
and uh you are very happy here you will
win that pawn back for example castles
you're gonna go queen side castles
and now you can uh win the pawn because
the the knight here is spin but it is uh
my it is a much trickier move to play so
instead after e5 we have e3
harvest prepares to start developing his
king's side
and morphe castles here we have bishop
to d3
trying to bait morphy into going e4 and
while it's not a
not a mistake it maybe allows the whites
to consolidate a bit too much for
example bishop to e2 now you can play
bishop to f4 play h4 h5
and so on white has a white has a very
good setup for example if d6 h4
and now if h6 just bishop to f4 it's a
perfectly fine position for white
and uh well it it it's okay for both but
uh maybe morphe can do better so instead
of uh
uh well committing to this right away he
goes d6 first
just defends the f5 pawn as it was under
attack
uh we have knight to e2 and only now uh
h6 pushing back this bishop and now the
knight has to be captured if you go back
uh your bishop just gets trapped here
after f4
so after h6 uh harvest captures on f6
with bishop captures morphy recaptures
with the queen
and uh now a3 and now you could go back
with bishop to a5 but bishop captures on
c3 is also playable so uh bishop
captures on c3 is what morphe goes for
queen captures and now queen to g6
putting pressure on this g2 pawn
and now uh harvest has to decide whether
to castle whether to try and
maybe do something else whether to maybe
castle queenside and try to use the
semi-open g file for attack if morphe
captures on g2
but he decides to castle king side and
this is perfectly fine
we have knight to d7 now morphy starts
bringing the other
knight into the attack and now b4
harvest again with the correct idea
uh he is stronger on the queen side and
he wants something like
captures and captures and then he can
start to push that
pushing that c pawn create a pass pawn
in the center of the board and so on
so morphe just defends it with b6 and
only now f3 keeping everything flexible
here
uh waiting for for morphe to make an
advance with
with one of the pawns and in fact if you
go for something like e4
just captures captures bishop to c2
black
didn't really achieve anything white is
very happy to trade here
uh he can bring the other rook over to
f1 and
this uh e4 pawn will not be all that
strong the bishop attacks that the
knight can also join the attack
so nothing to look forward here for
black so instead after f3
morphy starts with h5 he wants to play
h4 h3
and start an attack against the white
king so here
bishop to c2 preparing to shift the
bishop over to a4 and put pressure on
this knight here also bishop to c6 is an
idea
in some lines so bishop to b7 by morphe
continuing development connecting rooks
and now bishop to a4
as planned and now while morphy could
start with knight to f6
try to bring his knight into the game uh
here you could run into something like
f4
uh morphy could block this and then
bishop the c6 is very strong for white
so instead after bishop to a4 morphy
just defends the knight queen to f7
and here harvest uh decides to capture
the uh
knight and he does bishop captures his
played queen captures and now
uh there is no good reason uh to capture
this knight because bishop captures
knight
uh okay this knight is perhaps a very
strong piece but the bishop wasn't bad
either and now if you allow morphe to
capture on b4 you're going to be left
with uh
well with a backwards c for pawn it's a
very it will be very hard to advance at
the
the b and d pawn are covering the c5
square so here
uh harvest is kind of uh forced to
capture here if he doesn't want to
suffer
uh with this weakness for the rest of
the game so be captures
uh we have b captures and now only now
uh we have
f4 uh so offering uh
to trade on f4 morphe of course advances
the pawn we have e4 now closes the
position
uh and now rook ate the b1 uh so what do
you do here
here morphe goes for bishop to a6 now he
puts pressure on c4
he wants to play queen to a4 to pile up
on this c4 pawn and
now he wants to of course also double
rooks and the b files so this is the
plan
what will harvest do about it harvest
goes rook f to c1
and morphe continues with queen to a4
now putting pressure on the pawn here
knight to g3 going after well putting
pressure on this pawn but really going
after the h5 pawn and morphe just pushes
h4
uh we have knight to f1 now shifting the
knight over to d3
and now comes rook a to b8 and here like
i said morphe wants to trade off
the rooks along the b file but also if
white is not interested morphe will just
double rooks rook b6 rook f2
b8 and then continue uh putting pressure
uh along the queen side so knight to d2
and now rook to b6 as planned and here
we have
rook captures on v6 uh instead of going
for something like this you could also
try something like
king to f2 or maybe g3 g4 try and weaken
the e4 pawn
but harvest decides to trade right away
so rook captures
we have eight captures on b6 and now
comes a queen to b3
offering a queen trade and trying to go
for an end game
but again king to f2 or something like
g4 maybe improve the position a little
bit before
uh committing to the queen trade but
okay harvest goes for the queen trade
queen to b3
and the morphe very happily accepts
queen captures knight captures and now
b5 and with this move uh morphy has
created a past
c pawn and he will be uh well very very
happy to start pushing it off the board
or in this case down the board
so c captures on b5 with bishop captures
on b5
and now knight to a5 preparing knight to
b7 to go after the d6 pawn
morphy goes to rook to a8 and now knight
the b7
attacking the pawn hoping for a rook
capture spawn and then knight captures
this pawn but morphy just defends it
rook to a6
and now it's a question how this knight
will uh
will be saved because if you just allow
the king to approach the knight the
knight will be lost so here
rook the c3 first defending the a3 pawn
and now
king to f8 morphy starts uh bringing the
king closer and closer to the knight
so the knight has to move knights to d8
you want to play knight to e6
but morphy doesn't allow it just bishop
to d7 now taking care of all of these
squares
and of course the knight now can move
but you will simply capture it and then
win the pawn so it doesn't really do
anything so here
rook to b3 but just kink to e7
attacking the knight and now harvest
defends it we've broke the b8 but now
with harvest pieces tied down
on the back rank morphy starts uh
advancing his past pawn so here's c4
and uh stan uh uh sorry not stanton
loventhal
uh was uh analyzing this game and he
said that uh as of this moment
the skillful manner in which mr morphy
terminated the game commands our praise
and is deserving of close attention so
uh as uh as uh he uh
uh he so advises uh pay very close
attention so here morphy starts pushing
the past pawn c4
uh and king to f2 harvest of course has
to bring the king into the game with c3
and now comes
king to e2 we have rook captures on a3
by morphe and now
knight the c6 would check and the knight
has to be captured if you allow the
knight
to come to d4 for example the knight
will be a very very strong defender here
so bishop captures we have d captures on
c6 now harvest also gets a pass pawn
but now c2 uh morphe is ready to queen
his pawn but it's not a problem because
harvest will just defend king to d2
but this position is now completely lost
for morphe so
for harvest so feel free to pause the
video and win the game for morphe while
i give you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
wonderful idea
and for those of you who just want to
enjoy the show it is of course rook the
c3
i remember seeing this uh seeing this
maneuver a long long time ago and then
when you when you have such a such a
position
in your own games you will instantly
spot it because it it is of course a
very natural move
uh you are offering the rook for the
queening of the pawn it makes sense but
it it is harder
um it's not very hard to miss you know
if you don't know where to look so if
the rook is captured you bring the queen
into the game and
it's game over so here harvest is forced
to blockade the past pawn king to c1 but
now just rook captures on c6 and now
you have this rook and pawn end game
where morphe is just up two pawns and
this is now completely winning uh but
harvest will make for a morphe fight uh
for his meal so
rook to b3 uh and
now of course defending the pawn and
king to f6 by morphe we have rooked
a3 and now g5 morphe starts pushing the
pawns on the king side as well we have
g3
h captures h captures and now again a
captures captures here we have kinked
the g6 now morphe wants to infiltrate uh
via the king side to go after the e3
pawn and now
rook to a5 putting pressure on this pawn
so rook to c5 morphe offers a rook trade
because he's up two pawns so why not
uh and rook to a6 now uh pressuring this
pawn we
rook to c3 even allowing harvest to grab
this pawn with check but it doesn't
matter
rook captures with check king to h5 and
now
rook to d2 going after the d2 the c2
pawn but uh
morphy says no problem just king to g4
and here you cannot trade because after
captures captures and captures yes
you've equalized but only
for a moment because after king to f3
king to d2
morphy has king to f2 and now you have
the opposition white king has to move
from the defense of the pawn this is not
available this is not available so
whatever you do
just captures then captures and of
course the two connected past pawns are
winning
so after king to g4 harvey said all
right we cannot capture that
rook the g to check but just king to f3
we have rook to g5 going after the pawn
now again hoping for captures and
captures
but morphy just defends it there's
there's no problem here we have rook to
h5 but now
king captures on e3 we have rook to h4
defending the pawn but here
uh morphy just played king to f3 and it
was in this position that
uh daniel harvitz resigned in the game
as there was nothing more to be done
here
uh or rather let me just check maybe
maybe one more move was played
i'm not really sure uh but no no no
after king to f3 harvest resigned as
there was nothing more to be done here
uh you're playing king to g3 then the
rook will have to move and then you will
gobble up this point as well so it
doesn't matter if rook h3 just king
king wherever you can go king to g4 and
then that's just it the rook will have
to move somewhere doesn't really matter
you're gonna capture this pawn and now
with the two connected pass pawns you
are completely winning
so after king to f3 not only did morphy
win the game but he also won his first
game of the match so harvest is still
leading in the match it's two to one uh
but as
morphy said after he lost the second
game uh mr harvest will not
win a single game uh uh for the rest of
the match so we'll see
if morphe's bold claim will will come
true or
will uh harvest uh be able to score a
point it's still very early in the match
but
uh you know uh the next game in the
match game four
is such a beauty if you don't if you
haven't seen it don't
don't google it you know wait for it
because it's it's quite a nice one
or you know do if you can't wait uh but
yeah
uh that's the game i hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank uh
dorson kamkerton
antonis antonio hey sin uh mark lefosic
and
uh christian ginod for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
uh as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day